Wildcat
Doctor Mid-nite! Stripesy, get out! Run!
Hour Man!
Welcome to the show.
Starman! I told you to wait in the car!
Brainwave
Get it out
The Justice Society. They're gone.
Come on, we gotta get out of here.
Grundy
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Justice Society video for
DC TV is all going to be stargirl episode
one stuff in this video but I will talk
about what's going on with the Justice
Society on that TV show and how that
relates to Justice League stuff in the
DC TV series so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we'll do an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which other
Justice Society characters from the
comics you want to see come on to the
series what I'll do is I'll talk about
this clip first then I'll talk about all
the crisis on Infinite Earths DC TV
multiverse stuff that's going on Justice
League
Easter eggs because there's so much
stuff to unpack just in this opening
scene from stargirl episode 1 that is
crazy so if you don't know what's going
on there's a new stargirl TV series its
basically a Justice Society TV show but
you're just getting the Justice Society
from stargirls perspective she's the
main character this opening scene is
meant to give you a bunch of the
backstory and to sort of establish what
the Justice Society is within this earth
because per crisis on Infinite Earths in
that post-credit scene we found out that
this is all happening on earth too
the reason why it's earth 2 and not
earth Prime is because most of you will
know that Justice Society comes from
earth 2 in DC Comics history the Justice
Society was basically all of DC's Golden
Age heroes teaming up before there was a
Justice League when they got to the
Silver Age of comics DC rebooted a lot
of their comic book titles introducing
newer versions of all the heroes like
instead of Jay Garrick it was Barry
Allen becoming the flash then they
formed the Justice League in what later
writers would do to sort of bring in
those Golden Age heroes and explain that
they didn't go away they didn't
completely replace them they still
existed somewhere is they used the
multiverse and what they did is they did
the flash of two worlds where Barry
Allen vibrates so fast that he winds up
on earth to meeting Jay Garrick in all
the Golden Age heroes then they started
doing big Justice League Justice Society
crossovers so they kind of introduced
that idea through crisis on Infinite
Earths all this stuff happening on the
stargirl TV show is on earth too and
because this is Justice Society TV show
pretty much any classic Justice Society
character is fair game there's a bunch
of them featured in this opening
there's a bunch of them that you don't
see that I'll talk about during the
video too so the episode begins with the
injustice society led by icicle
successfully destroying most of the
Justice Society in their mansion the
mansion itself actually belongs to Starman because within the context of the
show he's sort of the Bruce Wayne Batman
of the team he's the really rich guy
that just uses his fortune to fund the
team what are your superpowers again I'm
rich
obviously you recognize he's being
played by Joel McHale which i think is a
huge get I would have never expected
Joel McHale to be on one of the DC TV
shows this is pretty crazy so that's how
much money they spent making this and
that's why it looks so much better to
Luke Wilson is playing his former
sidekick because he's one of the few
characters that's still alive in
present-day so as he's driving his car
up this is the one that he actually
modifies later and eventually uses to
create the stripes robot stripes as an
acronym for the comics like Stars and
Stripes he pilots it like a giant mech
it's around 16 to 20 feet tall when it's
standing up it's big enough for stargirl to ride on his back when he's
flying through the air but it has a
whole bunch of functions but his
character is basically like an engineer
a mechanic type person that just builds
a lot of tech he rolls up just as the
battle is peaking as you can see the
first one to go is Wildcat they're
basically killing off old members of the
team now not all of them are dead even
though it seems like all of them are
dead after this battle but all the green
flames that you see are from Alan
Scott's Green Lantern battery that's
right they can do Alan Scott Green
Lantern on the series so that's why
you're seeing all this stuff happening
here she goes crazy as he's dodging all
these energy blasts and magic blasts but
if you can't tell there are tons of
artifacts and easter eggs for comic book
stuff all over the mansion during the
show we're actually going to go back here
and see this stuff in much greater
detail so when we get to future episodes
they have any really big stuff then I'll
point it out in videos all this isn't
being shot and one continuous take but
it's pretty close to being shot in one
take you can tell that they spent the
budget of an entire DC TV show just on
this five minutes worth of footage at
the beginning here up in the balcony you
see our man fighting tigress they have a
version of artemis croc on the show
later who's going to  show up and they help
sports master who you see later during
this fight this here is the wizard
giving him the business from behind he's
one of the founding members of the
injustice society obviously he
recognized doctor mid-nite and then when
Joe
Kayle shows up his Starman he's fighting
the gambler yes there was a member of
the injustice society in the Golden Age
comics called the gambler who was
basically just a trickshot in a really
good gambler no real special powers to
speak of Starman manages to fight off
tigress and Sportsmaster but icicle is
the one who takes credit for killing him
you see Jay Garrick's helmet as they're
running away implying that he's died or
something's happened to him and then we
see a version of solomon grundy chasing
them down for the first time this is
like the epically upgraded version of
Grundy from what you saw on the Gotham
TV series on Fox a long time ago but the
important thing to remember is that even
though it seems like they kill all the
Justice Society members in this attack
some of them are still alive in present
day and will show up on the series like
doctor fate Johnny Thunder both of the
Hawks Hawkman and Hawkgirl there's a
bunch more there's even a janitor who
stares at stargirl like he knows her in
the hallway here but in the credits of
the episode he's just listed as janitor
Justin so he's probably going to either be
just an Arthur aka the shining Knight
because he kind of wears a hat that
seems like it has a symbol of a knight
riding a horse on it he could wind up
being Johnny Thunder or doctor fate but
anytime the camera lingers on one of the
adults or older people in present-day
it's because they're secretly either a
member of the Justice Society or the
injustice Society a lot of you probably
picked up a very spider-man homecoming
in Buffy the Vampire Slayer vibe Geoff
Johns said that's on purpose because
it's set around highschool characters
that are doing that Buffy the Vampire
Slayer thing where people in plain sight
members of the community that seem like
they're totally normal are secretly
really big villains or really big heroes
like I can't remember which season it
was but one of the seasons on Buffy the
principal of the high school was one of
the main villains they're kind of doing
that same thing here and during the
post-credits scene in crisis on Infinite
Earths some of you may have spotted that
the members of this Justice Society look
very different that's because this
lineup here are basically all the kids
she sits down with at the losers table
at lunch
so they'll all pick up the mantle of
some of the Justice Society heroes like
I said some of the old ones are still
alive in present day like doctor fate or
Alan Scott Green Lantern you also have
people that reincarnate like the Hawks
Hawkgirl Hawkman later in the episode
you find her staring at a picture of all
the members is not every single member
to ever have been
part of the Justice Society it just
meant to be a version of the final
roster right before this big battle so
look at the other characters you see
here you'll wind up seeing them on the
show eventually Hawkgirl Hawkman doctor
fate Alan Scott Green Lantern Johnny
Thunder in Thunderbolt and in Sandman
and the others we see during that
opening scene Wonder Woman was a
founding member of the original Justice
Society but I don't know if they're
allowed to do her just because the
Wonder Woman 1984 movie so don't count
on seeing any big Wonder Woman stuff
happening here I don't know what all
their plans are for dropping this stuff
on HBO max too because HBO max releases
next week and a lot of the DC TV shows
will also be on HBO max so just another
way to get the episodes we'll get some
more details about that sometime soon
but geoff johns is basically in charge
of this show because he created the stargirl
character he's also in charge of
the new Green Lantern HBO series that
they're doing but he hasn't said when
that's going to premiere I've already done
a couple videos about that so I'll link
one of them at the end of this they've
been asked a little bit about the
characters and the storylines that
they're doing they're doing pretty much
what you would expect them to do the big
easy slam dunks most of that will be a
little bit different from the DC TV
stuff because it'll be set in outer
space with the Green Lantern Corps so
you probably won't see them cross over
quite as much with the DC TV stuff next
year's DC TV crossover will mostly be a
Superman Batman riff with fewer
characters and it'll be two hours long
instead of being three or four hours
long but hopefully that explains what's
going on with the Justice Society inside
the TV show universe now so stargirl
very much doing Justice Society stuff if
you're a big fan of that everyone click
here for my Justice League Snyder cut
teaser trailer and breakdown of what's
going on with that project and click
here for my green lantern series HBO
teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight!